[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu fais quoi ici un summer ville bah en
fait ma mère veut pas le dire mais on
n'a plus d'argent
tout ce qui nous reste c'est une vieille
ferme flippante que mon grand père nous
a laissé en pleine cambrousse
ah d'accord c'est encore plus pourri que
ce que je pensais
j'ai trouvé ça dans mon salon où c'est
une superbe copier une copie de quoi
dans piège la phantom on n'a pas signalé
de fantôme depuis 30 ans new york dans
les années 80 c'était comme the walking
dead
ton père tu en a jamais parlé j'ai que
ma mère
mon grand père est mort pour ma mère on
est là pour trier tous les vieux trucs
qu'il a laissé
à temps
et qui est dû
fatalité
chance ou carmes
m tout arrive pour une bonne raison
allez on m'appelle
y'a un poste artillerie
moi c'est pas croyable j'ai jamais rien
vu d'aussi cool